[Music]
[Applause]
Frank Isola the Annette Studio host and
uh Sirius XM NBA Radio the starting
lineup and a contributor to Around the
Horn pardon the interruption where do
you want to start Frank
I think we should start here I need to
work on the show as well because I'm
just like your crew I don't subscribe to
some of these
um you know websites and accounts you
guys are only reading up to where it
starts where it says you have to
subscribe how great so it was some huge
breaking story I love how you guys throw
it out there if anybody else has read
the rest of the story can you kind of
call in and tell us what it's all about
that is absolutely brilliant yeah
there's cost cutting measures here Frank
you know I don't work for ESPN anymore
it's behind a paywall guys you can't
tell you the rest of the story we just
saw the Daniel side we think he wants to
sell the team that's great all right
help me understand
uh let me play it for everybody here
here's Kevin Durant being asked the
question yesterday
when did you find out about Steve how
were you informed
about 1 15 I woke up from my nap and
turned to the right and seen on ESPN
and what were your I mean initial
reaction I mean everybody knows what's
what went on this summer but what was
your first thought when you saw that oh
shocked I mean you're always shocked
when a move like this happens but it's
normal in the NBA you know so it's about
getting ready for the game tonight so
it's a quick tournament always in the
league you know especially during the
season you know you got practice games
coming up so you can't think too much
about it but it was one of mine for a
little bit today yeah how could he be
shot I'm shocked that he's shocked
because he wanted this guy fired in the
off season do you think Nets management
ran this by Kevin Durant
oh come on if they didn't he clearly
made it made it known over the summer
and Brian Lewis from the New York Post
was going to ask that question I like
Brian but I really don't care what Kevin
Durant was it wasn't where were you when
man landed on the moon I don't care what
Kevin Durant was doing and to use the
word shock
come on now Kevin over the summer the
report came out that you said Sean marks
the GM Steve Nash head coach go or iGo
One of the other then they all came
together and said well that's not going
to happen but come on Dan we've been
doing this for a long time when a
superstar player comes out and says
something like that the clock is clearly
ticking you start off under Steve Nash
two and five you cannot tell me that
you're shocked and then shock it up well
this is normal in the NBA really is it
really it happens all the time where
star player first demands to be traded
then when that's not going to work out
he says well tell you what get rid of
the coach in the gym then I'll come back
so Kevin Durant being slightly
disingenuous there I just wish someone
had said to him do you feel like what
you did over the summer
contributed at the very least to Steve
Nash being fired because we all know
that it did come on I would like for
them to take some ownership here I know
it's not going to happen but you know
just say look you know it didn't work
out we wanted him here and uh you know
what part of the I'll take part of the
blame like I'd love I'd love for one of
these guys eyes to just do that but they
you know they they push it away
um you know then you got the Kyrie
situation they didn't even let let him
get in front of the media yesterday how
does this play out with uh the Nets and
or the NBA with with Kyrie and to your
point too about accountability I always
say you know the great thing about
player empowerment is you know you get
to call all the shots but you're never
held accountable when the whole thing
falls apart and that's kind of where
Kyrie Irving and Kevin Durant certainly
are right now I don't know how it's
going to play out if it's going to be
madeau can I get it he coached here for
one year and Kevin Durant Kyrie Irving
from everything that we've heard they
like Hime adoka I felt like they liked
Steve Nash in fact Monday night against
Indiana the Nets played really well I
had heard that on Saturday night after
they were terrible against Indiana Steve
Nash really lit into the players
including Kevin Durant it was a little
back and forth there so this idea that
he lost the locker room then they
wouldn't have competed like that on
Monday night against Indiana but I to me
this is a Hail Mary by the organization
Marie mayodoka let's see if he could
save the season it's still only November
2nd so you know guys that were signed
over the summer they become eligibly
betrayed you know it's either starts
December 15th or in January so I still
think there's a chance that something
can happen they'll revisit all those
teams uh Phoenix Miami who knows maybe
the Golden State Warriors so I think all
that stuff with Kevin Durant is going to
start up again especially if the Nets
continue on this path with right now one
of the worst teams in the Eastern
Conference we know that you can't just
have this transaction where you go we're
going to fire a coach and then we're
going to hire a coach and you do that
over 48 or 72 hours how long has this
been in the works do you think behind
the scenes you know and it's a great
point I said the same thing you know who
knows when they first how do you know
that if when they first suspended the
Celtics suspended email yodoka the Nets
in reach out then that's very possible
you cannot tell me that over the last 48
hours you fired Steve Nash you contacted
the Boston Celtics which is a
complicated situation and you almost
have an agreement in place with email
I'm not buying that so clearly this has
been something that's been going on for
a while could it have been as far back
as last week could have been uh you know
Saturday night after they lost Indiana
perhaps it started then but the wheels
have been turning on something like this
because it's a very unique such
situation the guys currently suspended
by his own team for a full season he
served right now I think he's about 30
31 days and it looks like he could be
coaching the Nets at some point this
weekend or maybe next week
I don't understand how the Celtics can
go oh you like you want him uh he was
coach of the Air Force you can have him
we don't want any compensation like that
would really concern me if I'm a Celtic
fan you have all the leverage here why
not just say we want a first round pick
for the guy who was the coach of the
year granted he's suspended but if I'm
the Nets and I'm getting
udoka do I know exactly what happened
with the Boston Celtics with that
relationship and I think part of it too
is getting off of his money so now you
don't have to worry about negotiating a
buyout with him which I think that was
probably the net or a settlement I
should say that was going to be the
situation with email yadoka but to your
point and now I think the Celtics could
this this could cause some trouble in
their locker room as well because he
mayodoka obviously popular with the
players there especially the star
players Jason Tatum Jalen Brown Mark is
smart wouldn't they be saying well hang
on a second he can't coach our team but
he's allowed to go coach a team in in
our division a team that we lost it two
years ago in the playoffs and he gets to
coach Kevin Durant and Kyrie Irving now
but he can't coach us we just went to a
finals that doesn't make any sense when
does the NBA engage with Kyrie Irving
here
I don't know it seems like they're a
little late on it I mean they did come
out and release a statement last week
Kyrie Irving's name was not included in
the statement also the Players
Association released a statement I think
it was yesterday Kyrie Irving's name was
not mentioned in the statement I just
don't understand why Kyrie Irving I have
a funny feeling that he didn't watch the
entire documentary why he just doesn't
come out and say I heard about this uh
about this documentary what my friend or
what I read about it I had no idea it
included all these but he doesn't
apologize Frank and you know and Dan the
problem is if he apologizes and
explained it like that I think most
people would say yeah I understand and
people want to be forgiving instead he's
digging his heels and except he did take
the post down the social media post and
I think in the way that he played last
night I don't know maybe he heard with
Charles Barkley and the gang was saying
about him during the pregame because
Kyrie Irving had played very well up
until last night last night he was
completely out of it did not score a
point until the fourth quarter he just
wasn't himself so clearly the pressure
the Press pressure and the stress of
everything that's going on I think is
finally getting to them great to talk to
you as always Frank thanks for joining
us good seeing you guys take care Frank
Isola the Annette Studio host on yes uh
also SiriusXM NBA Radio the starting
lineup and contributor to around the
horn and pardon the interruption